talking about the last us open counting
new construction it's
writing we see him in to the
youtube algorithms boards we two
describe a sad for the present
sources and what they also describes a
move
against promoting inspiration type
content en wie het already know this
very early on that we were in medio
losing you as numbers you switch million
views per man of youtubes
recommendations old age
in media youtube medicina with many
months ago
and how fast it led sunday de pentecostal
which has been following and
gathering and love this information and
reading  about it up bed show where
everything that is happening is i say
will you and harmina exact usb products
and it's not there any special insight
it was just a few hot attention to the
combination over youtubers an
and what is happening to our channel i
was very  queer anger was that was could
help so tired who after the chairman at
this point
is what is so slim de this talk my
show of
reasonable collateral  damage votes
just had to accept the cross wie wat
youtube to be cautious
bel this conspiracy contently coitus
reasonably getting her ass and inside or
is this an acceptable in terms of
collateral damage de swing suffered by
nang conspiracy
independent media drivers so no
question mark's research spines
she the deepest ever kind of conspiracy and
us arbiter at youtube [ __ ] wordjes de
go en is mark rights recommendations de
deepest conspiracy channels like'n
excuse network of drastically reduce if
you look at the number of
recommendations to align with the
conspiracy channels and they found
i stand cleo youtube they the demons too
expensive so in that sense youtube house six
siege
public with cities demons to do the
house inside change interestingly
enough with regard to this sort of flash
drive center politics of balance of the
recommendations and this is one single
ipad of the ministry my name is
on joe rogan program we have
strike 2nd note t  empura als iphone never had
in fast youtubers doing and in
her politics oh my god
whether you were left right of center
what was happening with youtube is
starting to prioritize
legacy korper content about independance
content en to thick state independer
content outside of the conspiracy
chandra can  the left right person or
iphone oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh en in the market research fund de
thinking and get one you look at the
balance of how is winning is a
result is exactly as be started
singing the very beginning the  winners of
corporate media
crazy so one question unreasonable
issues of youtube is recommending the
conspiracy channels les in was
what happens when you go and watch
videos on those channels wat is de
youtube hit least you in cities en is
een i simple
deo recommending of fax new
sadistic comparison of before and
after recommendations from the
conspiracy channels 2 fox news
how is that in stars recommend
in a  other conspiracy channels am
already here for your iphone or the conspiracy
channels
youtubers recommending fox news
significantly more mike ssd museum with cnn
msnbc the figure is so better amina it
is slightly beds writzer de this is
also use korper hen die would you rather'
someone whose  in the conspiracy rubber
holla youtube
get recommend it more conspiracy driver
hol videos or a club of msnbc and in
arona with ferry ferry
surf ipad radical what this is the big
picture result that is hurting as i'm
talking about this for you almost since
the  beginning this is how big girl get
crashes in the mooc wow of coke
conspiracy channel
and george tower t des sources what
happens if i get swimcap hello it
manager channels like ours
en mark actually mentions as senco this
is at the news for men youtube
creators leakdetec  my
apple-dumpling progressive talk show
host that is careful about the quality of
information in a show these changes
and increased recommendations to  our
partners and channel's life boxes msnbc
hoe regularly miss represent caravans and
promo conspiracy theory sonology
supplications complete the google looks
beats beatbox and msnbc in the conspiracy
sleigh promo pack in any case marco son to
write a like they put a quick response
the old rhythm  adversaries diversifiers
distribution twitch and obtaining
stream from come directly dear and
supporters de was website so mix in was
i s'pose je die algorithm god 6
youtubers decided to meter platform
upraising de corporate media and
advertisers creators new de te moe
voor diversify showcase platforms and
create
leverage and then maybe had to
devastatingly re-use the deeds for
specifically winners and losers of all
so our channel is one of the most
negative effects in search of
recommendations from the cell the ride with
changes to the solutions there sabrina
glamorous pdf flyer en ninja  was slightly
supporter shows you directly here is and
in the planet earth and it took i tell
yo  u this is his research and wooden
board is cool y'all de risotto of what
up and down on youtube old age is dat
is krishna's so supporters stretch
li-fi light go where to get tested and
support whatever she realized how to
show you like more than  this one and you
say hi guy [ __ ] a man to contribute
amineko demonstrative task my push it
wit as you go website join task my that
can you pick up a membership at
reeleezee
boushaba xbox him under sixty for the
here is that is 250 problem so  the
coupon code this is tony tony and usa for
the percent
you can be so corrupt already called rian dot com
slash this talk to show a prophase bucks
there two man that will ramifications at and
dictate remixes
1st where this effing phone
office hours
that this is a fortune  oil too
stiff here